you just feel like you are climbing a
mountain
every day and every day you get up
and the same mountain is a ahead of you
my wee girl abby who was 12 at the time
hopped in the car with her best friend
ella and ella's
mum who was also a really dear friend of
mine
and on the way down a driver sped
straight through a stop sign crashed
into them
and killed all three of them so
i just have this peculiar insight really
that you know i've done the
academic study i've ruled over all of
the research
and then i've had to really test
what works in a really obviously
horrifically
personal way and i can say that i feel
really lucky now
because having had that training i did
at least have
some tools at my fingertips but i want
to make a really
important point here that too often
people
focus on resilience thinking it's just a
personal thing
and actually we know that it's much much
bigger than that not seeing yourself
represented in society
is potentially damaging for your
resilience
whether it's race sexuality ability
mental illness any form of prejudice
like that that feeling that you don't
belong you're not seen and you're not
heard
is hurtful and productive when it comes
to resilience
so why is it important for a country to
be resilient
because it enables us to mobilize our
resources faster
and in that i mean everything from
portaloos to
trust think about our ever-changing
environments that we
know we all live in nowadays bushfires
covet the earthquakes you know change
and adversity come
thick and fast and resilient society's
resilient
nations are so much better able to
respond in that time to be able to
protect their weak
their vulnerable to be able to protect
the economy to
weather whatever comes in a much
better way so on that personal
perspective
the good news is that research shows
that resilience really
requires what we call ordinary magic
it's not some elusive trait that is
only available to a few we can teach
people
to be more resilient the three
strategies that i
relied on when the girls died and to be
fair i
absolutely still rely on now i've
wheeled them all out again recently
are the number one is understand that
suffering
is part of life whether it is
divorce or redundancy losing a partner
really
tough things happened to us all so
knowing that
going into this terrible experience
knowing
that adversity was common and that
suffering was common
really did make a difference because it
prevented me from feeling
singled out number two
tune into the good we get sucked into
what we call in psychology and
negativity bias you know we're really
good
humans are looking at all the crappy
bits but actually we're not so good at
tuning into the good stuff and it's
really really important
for us to counterbalance that by
choosing to focus our attention
on some of the good stuff and resilient
people are really
careful to choose where they focus their
attention
number three ask yourself
is this helping or harming me
is the way i'm thinking is the way i'm
acting right now
helping or harming me in my quest to get
through this
all too often people think that
resilience is about that
good old stiff upper lip and it's not
that at all
actually being resilient is also being
able to
accept your vulnerabilities knowing when
you need to
get help and to reach out studies have
shown
that having strong supportive
relationships
is probably the most important thing
we can do to build resilience we were
really lucky
we had a really supportive community
who helped us and all of this is what
you need when you navigate
trauma and adversity nobody goes it
alone
and one of the key researchers in the
field chris peterson used to say
other people matter that that was the
three-word
summary of his decades of research
you